joining me now is stephen miller former
senior adviser to president trump
founder of america first legal and
florida congressman byron donalds
congressman i want to begin with you uh
what we saw today in congress
was truly disturbing the suggestion
that to fight china we need to
saturate our military marinate our
military
and the divisive works of of these
racial agitators
your response and why are we paying for
this
just as concerned as you are the last
thing our men and women in uniform need
to be doing is reading that book from
eber max candy
they need to be focused on two things
number one being prepared
for any of the issues that our country
may face in the future
and number two being a united force a
united front
men and women from all walks of life
from all races across our country
we are one america we are one people and
if we go down this road that the
critical race theorists
want us to go down or we start looking
at each other's as enemies
instead of understanding number one the
history of our country but also also
understanding
the progression we've made as america
and that we're all united to face the
foes that face our country
we're going to be lost this is not good
for our military it's not good for our
country
uh stephen miller i i gotta say
republicans
in congress they have the power to
take some of the money away from the
military when it's doing what it's doing
shawn's report about the vaccination at
west point they're
harassing and oppressing these young
cadets
who either have the antibodies or some
other reason for not wanting the vaccine
and and now this and this admiral looks
extremely dismissive of congress
i found his entire tone to be highly
annoying
and completely disrespectful to the
congressional oversight that's needed
there's a stunning level of arrogance
and frankly hubris too
i think if you were a member of the
chinese communist party
looking to hurt america looking to
damage military and unit cohesion
looking to degrade our armed services
you could not do better than to teach
our service members
the hateful ideologies of critical race
theory
i think that what needs to happen is
that republicans in congress need to
fight
to include an appropriations writer in
the next defense bill
making very clear that no taxpayer
dollar shall be spent
to instruct anybody in the military in
critical race theory
period and dare democrats to block it
yeah well congressman would you be in
favor of that
i'm just glad that stephen gave me an
amendment for the defense bill because
i'd be happy to author it
listen laura this is very simple if you
want to talk about the history of race
in america
let's talk about it let's teach it let's
be fully complete about
it let's not hide names let's teach it
all but critical race theory
theory is not about the objectivity of
our history when it comes to race
it's about subjectivity a funnel through
a prism of marxism and political
ideology
that the democrats could never get
through the united states
if everybody was actually happy with our
nation
you must first divide our nation in
order to push
the political ideology that they want
and that's the danger of critical race
theory
it has no base in our schools no base in
our military
and frankly if the theorists want to
discuss it in academia
let them do that on their own time
taxpayer money should not go forward
with it not a dime not one
dime and republicans better wake up to
this stephen
i want to move on to something else
attorney general garlic merrick garland
reversed the trump administration's
rulings on asylum standards politico
reports
that this means that immigration judges
will be free again to grant asylum to
individuals based on threats of domestic
abuse
or violence from drug gangs some of the
whose claims were already denied
could benefit from a justice department
review of the cases
so stephen this is actually going back
to cases that were already determined
and perhaps plucking those people out of
where
wherever they are and allowing them to
come into the united states how is this
not
facilitating asylum fraud it's hard to
explain just how breathtakingly radical
this is
one of the greatest things that
president trump did for this country
was shutting down asylum fraud
categorically
by the time the 2020 rolled around
asylum fraud was a thing of the past it
was done
what merrick garland has done here is
extreme
it means that anyone in the world who
comes from a high crime country
which by the way is billions of people
or comes from a country where there's
high rates of domestic abuse
a great tragedy a terrible tragedy but
they can come to the united states
and they can demand asylum they can be
admitted and they can be made into a u.s
citizen this completely destroys the
integrity of our entire immigration
system
and it means there will be more fraud
than you can possibly imagine because
there's no way
to disprove a claim of being afraid of
violence it's an unfalsifiable assertion
and it's an attack
on the integrity of the entire asylum
immigrant
immigration system i mean i think all of
this is impeachable i'm sorry i think
it's a conspiracy to undermine u.s
immigration
and sovereignty everything that we
understand about law and order at our
border
it's it is breathtaking it's almost no
words for it congressman
that's not the only border surrender
though the state department and dhs
released a joint statement
saying we're proud to announce the
second phase of our central american
miners program reopening
this expansion of eligibility will now
include certain u.s based parents
or legal guardians who have a pending
asylum application
congressman this is basically a central
american airlift
into american communities if you've been
denied asylum or you're waiting
somewhere else
for your hearing you now can be brought
into the united states
and we will reunite you with your
family who are also here waiting for a
hearing that they'll probably never
attend
listen this is a complete and utter
disaster on our southern border
our border patrol men and women are
completely overwhelmed they've basically
been turned into a medical triage unit
their triage of medical conditions and
they're releasing people into the united
states
you take this new policy in with the
people who have already been turned down
or turned away you're going to
completely overwhelm
whatever semblance of border security
exists
and let's be perfectly clear the
president and his team are doing this
on purpose this is not a mistake he
doesn't have dementia
it's not that he doesn't know what's
going on he fully knows this is why he
won't go to the border this is why
kamala harris won't go to the border
they are doing this on purpose because
if border security is completely
overwhelmed
then they get to come with their next
plan which is to completely wipe out
immigration law
turn it into a turn style clicker in the
new york city public system
the train system that they have up there
so people can just come in freely
without any deterrence and by the way
laura all this is happening
while the cartel continues to make
billions of dollars
trafficking people and fentanyl into the
united states
every single day this is a travesty not
just for the southern border
but for the entire country they are
doing it on purpose
ron desantis agrees and greg abbott
agrees
this is purposeful they want this to
happen gentlemen
thank you both hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else